let me give you a secret sauce that's
worked for me since I was 21 years old
my peers showed up five days a week on
Friday night that leave at five o'clock
at state till 9:30 Friday nights I was
always late to the parties even when I
was 21 22
then later on my peers took Saturday's
off I worked very hard on Saturdays
matter of fact Saturdays was my number
one money-making day because I knew
everybody was home I could pick up and
get a hold you on Saturday it was the
best day of the week for me I look
forward to Saturday's and I would always
sit there and say guys you want to stick
on Saturday hey hey hey hey hey hey
nobody would be there right fast forward
today I'm 41 years old right 20 years
later it's Saturday I came here my kids
were still in bed I left the house
quietly nanny wasn't up nobody was up
and I came to the office and I've got so
much done this morning and it's not even
noon yet I've looked at all the data
I've looked at all the numbers I've
studied everything I need to I've read
articles current events read a book a
couple hours of reading a book while I'm
going to audible.com/veritasium great
story
it's the underrated version of Howard
Hughes who became richer and more
powerful than him and I'm listening to
him and I'll do my work yawn and I've
seen a bunch of things that's going on
and that Saturdays so look I know a lot
of people that are watching this you may
be watching this in your own bed you may
be watching this like come on bad why
are you being such a why are you ruining
my fourth of July I'm not trying to ruin
your fourth of July if you said you have
big dreams you're ruining your dreams I
didn't ruin your dreams I'm just telling
you what I'm doing and I told you it's a
secret sauce and it's a secret sauce
many of these people on the wall have
also followed many of them that guy
followed that guy definitely followed
the gap they're followed they followed
he probably followed those guys followed
all of those guys followed on Saturdays
so happy Independence Day happy fourth
of July but remember your independence
comes when you're willing to do things
your peers and others are simply not
willing to do and one of them is shown
up on
Saturdays